SPEAKER: Hello, and
welcome to Cloud Minute.
Today I'm going to talk about
managing SSH keys on Google
Compute Engine instances.
One of the challenges
many teams face
is controlling who has SSH
access to their Compute Engine
resources.
There are a lot of ways to
do this with code, including
various groups and tools.
But Compute Engine provides a
way to do it from the web UI
as well.
From Google Cloud Console,
click Compute Engine, Metadata.
And then click SSH Keys.
Now, to add an SSH
key, I click here.
You paste the whole key
in, and you click Save.
And the SSH keys
are propagated out
to all the Compute Engine
resources in your project.
Let's test it out.
And you can see I have SSH
access to that Compute Engine
resource.
When it comes time to revoke the
key, click Edit, click the X,
and then click Save.
And now you see I get a
Permission Denied error.
So if you've been struggling to
control or audit the SSH access
to your project, try this out.